And the other thing that's happening is
a new virus is spreading. So I got to be
careful what I say cuz I don't want to
get banned by YouTube.
A new virus is spreading. Now,
ironically,
this was brought to my attention by
James White. He warned, "Hey,
a new virus is about to hit.
They're planning
another possible shutdown." And I went
and checked, and he's right.
We'll talk about these things.
Be patient, guys. Take it easy. You know
the rules. Give me some time. We'll get
there.
Is it a coincidence this is all
unfolding at the same time?
This is all unfolding at the same time.
What's happening in the Middle East?
Trump is deliberately, right? Oh my
goodness, this guy again.
Trump is deliberately
egging on Iran. Supposedly ceasefire and
then bombs.
And Iran,
no pushover. They haven't been able to
do away with Iran. They're coming back
stronger, taking out ships, closing the
Strait of Hormuz, which may lead to
economic collapse.
That's happening because of Netanyahu,
fighting Israel's wars for them. So let
me show you here.
Okay, I'm going to play this clip in a
minute.
But let me show you what I posted on
Twitter.
Here's the latest virus, and here's
what's shocking to me. Someone sent this
to me, and I was shocked.
Do you know how you find,
right? Do you know how you find?
You'll find clips from Simpson shows 20
years ago, 10 years ago,
where the cartoons
talk about things that life imitates.
I've seen them, right? Well, one
that's similar I'm going to show you. So
if you go to my I didn't post one of
them on YouTube cuz I don't know how
they're going to react.
But here, if you go to my profile, watch
here. I found out
what the virus is called.
>> [clears throat]
>> Here's the new name for it.
It's
Han
Hantavirus.
And it we're told that some Americans
contracted it on a ship. Here it is. Let
me get you the link right here. The
Guardian.
Here it is.
It's breaking out.
Slowly they're going to make it into an
epidemic.
Here it is.
You go there. Let me show you Rumble.
Rumble, I haven't forgotten you.
Right? Here you go.
Yep.
Exactly, Pajoga. I'm seeing you guys. In
the beginning, King the Florist, Pajoga,
Keep It Real, Smiley. I haven't seen
Lord Jesus Christ Reigns. I hope he's
okay.
Okay, now watch here.
Let me go. Where is it?
Right here.
They're saying that a couple Americans
on a ship
contracted it and they've been
quarantined.
And it's now spreading.
The Guardian.
Americans on Hantavirus
cruise ship reportedly to be
quarantined in US.
See that? They're starting, guys.
You see how it's all converging?
You see it's all converging?
Files on
Yes, brother. Please don't share Ezekiel
38, Zephaniah 3, please.
Neil, I don't want to block you. Just
sit there, be patient. Good to see you
for us. Don't help me. Help me by not
helping me, quoting verses that you
think refer to the end time.
All right?
Okay, so
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> it's happening. Now, ironically, James
White mentioned they're planning it, and
I said, "What is he talking about?" And
cuz he watches news, but I don't. I I I
see what comes up on YouTube, but I got
to now
start reading the files on the aliens.
So, bear with me.
There you go.
Now, here's what's freaky.
Where did this virus broke out?
On a cruise ship. The Americans are for
the Americans, right?
One of the symptoms of Hantavirus is
purple tongue. Now, here's what someone
sent me.
Now, this freaked me out, too.
You tell me what's going on. You see
it's all how it's all converging?
A virus that's spreading, quarantine
people,
alien files being released, war in the
Middle East.
Is there a connection
that Trump is being used to bring about
the Antichrist?
Right?
Is there? I don't know. I'm not God, and
I'm not,
you know, one of those end time
preachers who calls you to panic. No,
I'm just saying,
what's going on?
Because right here, this was sent to me,
and I was like, "What?
You're kidding me."
Here, let me show you.
I shared this on my YouTube. Let me see
if I can find it here. Watch this.
This Someone sent it to me on my
Facebook. Watch.
This was years ago. Simpsons.
All right, um Look, THAT'S OUR SHIP.
PURPLE.
SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS. DID you guys That's
OUR SHIP.
PURPLE.
SOMEONE SENT THIS TO ME. IS IT REAL?
MUCUS. PURPLE. An emergency message.
Outbreak of the deadly virus is
spreading rapidly. A VIRUS?
A WORRYING new challenge in efforts to
contain the hantavirus.
What's going on here?
A scene from The Simpsons.
A virus breaks out
and one of the symptoms is purple tongue
on a ship.
I don't know much. I'm not saying I
don't know. Is it taken out of context?
Is Simpson lying?
On a ship.
And this is from years ago.
I'm live right now, brother.
It broke out on a ship.
And now
people are being quarantined.
What's going on here?
Hantavirus. Symptom is purple tongue.
Chris,
all we want right now is to feel safe.
>> [music]
>> For now, nobody is being allowed off the
boat. All ships must remain at sea. HAVE
FUN. MORE BOOZE.
I GOT TO PAUSE IT SO I DON'T get flagged
by YouTube.
But it's on Rumble, guys, so there you
go.
What's going on here?
Are they doing it to us again? And what
happened to Fauci?
What happened to Fauci?
Yeah, guys, you have to be ready now.
You can't give in now.
They They want to cause
a worldwide catastrophe cuz the masses
won't be controlled anymore.
It's happening again.
Where's Fauci? Does anyone know? He
disappeared, right?
They want Trump wanted And did you
notice another thing? I don't know if
you guys noticed it.
Did you know when COVID broke out? It
was during Trump's
first term.
Do you know who encouraged the
pharmacies to speed up the vaccination?
It was Trump. It wasn't Biden.
Do you guys forgot that part of history?
You guys who celebrated Trump.
And I thought he was going to be a man
of integrity because I thought no one
could put him in his place, but the
Epstein file shows that he's
compromised.
It happened during the term of Trump and
he's the one
who pushed the pharmaceuticals to come
up with a vaccination.
Do you guys forgot that that Trump was
part of this?
Right?
You see this?
Do you remember that or you guys forgot?
Yeah, so you think Trump and is it a
coincidence it's happening on Trump's
term again?
The man who told you he's going to
release the Epstein files, but now he
shuts it down. But now he's excited to
release alien files, not the Epstein
files.
But you platformed
on releasing the Epstein files and not
going to war.
And then
>> [clears throat]
>> getting rid of illegal aliens.
You're now the worst warmonger
right?
in recent history, worse than Biden.
Right? Maybe on the level of George Bush
because Netan- Netanyahu lied to
Congress
right? That
Saddam
was hiding weapons of mass destruction.
That turned out to be a lie. Go see it.
They said yeah, there was none.
As a pretext to attack Iraq and Iraq has
been in shambles ever since.
We're giving you receipts and wow,
brother.
>> [music]
>> It's the same disease that killed Betsy
Arakawa, the wife of late actor Gene
Hackman.
>> [music]
>> There you go.
According to the newspaper, FEMA was
called out to manage an outbreak of the
hantavirus.
What?
Wait, they even said it?
Let's see. According to the newspaper,
FEMA was called out to manage an
outbreak of the hantavirus.
Okay. The hantavirus? Sounds like it.
I'm just showing you what's there.
There you go.
So, notice what's happening. We shut
down
the Epstein files
but we now release alien files.
We're at war in Iran. Supposedly, they
want to liberate Iranian people even
though
right? Netanyahu with Trump
bombed a school full of Iranian girls
and blew them to smithereens. Is that
liberation? Oh, collateral damage.
You know, what are you going to do? It's
counter-terrorism.
Right? And then we have the scandal of
the synodal.
They're saying that there are some
priests are saying
that homosexuality is not sinful.
Raising the ire of Bishop Strickland.
And now Timothy Gordon's doing something
on it. You see what's happening?
You guys see what's happening?
All of this is converging, right?
And they're saying conspiracy.
When Trump just said he's going to
release the files on the aliens, alien
files, UAP, and he released the first
batch, I was told.
And then I just showed you from the
Guardian
Americans quarantined for the
Hantavirus.
That's it. Yeah, we're conspiracy. Yeah,
yeah, you're right.
Right?
>> [snorts]
[clears throat]
>> Right?
You get it now?